the cdc has cleared the way for all 12
to 15 year olds to get pfizer's coveted
vaccine so that means
young adolescents will be able to get
the shot nationwide starting today
now in a recent poll 30 percent of
parents said they would get kids in this
age group vaccinated right away but 23
said they would definitely not get them
inoculated president biden's chief
medical advisor dr anthony fauci joins
us
dr fauci we always love it when you're
here a lot of questions a lot of
concerns as always
when you come normally when you're here
people got lots of questions dr falchi
so here we go
you know parents parents i've heard
parents say look i'm willing to take a
risk
i'm not willing to take a risk for my
children so what do you say to them
for parents who are worried about the
long-term effects everybody just says
there's still so much unknown about this
vaccination
what do you say well that's not entirely
true
uh gail really the fact is that the
information that we have now with
literally
almost 200 million people having been
vaccinated here in the united states
and worldwide i mean we've administered
264
million doses in the united states
the safety profile is really quite firm
and sound so i mean first of all
you don't want to in any manner or form
have the parents feel like they're doing
something wrong by questioning
i mean it's the perfectly normal thing
to be concerned about your children
and to question and that's the reason
why you want to get them as much
information as you possibly can and be
very open and transparent about the
information
it is very important for children to get
vaccinated one because
even though it's quite true that if
children get infected
the seriousness of the infection in
children is
clearly less than the potential in
certain adults particularly the elderly
and those with underlying conditions but
we are starting to see younger people
get into serious trouble again at a very
low rate
but serious trouble but the other aspect
of it that they need to understand
is that when children get infected even
though they may not
in fact get serious illness they could
inadvertently and
innocently pass the infection on to
someone else perhaps another member of
the family
who is vulnerable and could get into
trouble are there long-term effects for
kids
you know when you say long-term effects
if you look at the history of
vaccinology
and you look at the time when you see
long-term effects you usually don't go
beyond
45 days after the vaccination
we do not let the vaccines out on an
emergency use authorization
until at least 60 days following
the time when half of the people have
received the last dose
in the clinical trial and we are well
beyond that right now
so we're well into almost a year of
people
having received the vaccine and there is
no long-term effects that anyone can
notice
dr fauci given given the importance that
you say getting kids vaccinated
uh that how important that is do you
think schools should require
kids to get vaccinated before they come
back to school
you know that is something that's
debatable i mean whenever you're talking
about requiring something that's always
a charged
issue so i'm not so sure we should be
requiring children at all we should be
encouraging them
but you've got to be careful when you
make a requirement of something that
usually gets you into
a lot of pushback understandable
pushback well let me ask you about
incentives because
ohio's governor mike dewan who's going
to be on this broadcast later this
morning
has offered a million dollar incentives
in a lottery form for people who get
vaccinations
if they if they get the shot five people
could be winners what do you think of
financial incentives for vaccinations
you know when you talk about
incentives there are incentives for a
variety of interventions so this would
not be unique
uh i mean there are different types of
incentives is very interesting
a rather creative one of the governor
there but
we have incentives to get people into
clinical trials and we have incentives
from people
to get involved in accepting
interventions so it's not a unique
concept uh dr fauci please help us with
the mass situation
i know we're told we can wear it outside
we don't have to wear it outside but i'm
telling you i was in new york where i
live
walking down the street i just stopped a
random lady and i said have you been
vaccinated she said yes
i said me too why are we wearing our
mask she goes i don't know
i mean because i think we all feel and i
said me
too ma'am me too i think we all either
feel guilty or we feel it's not time or
we see everybody
else doing it it's monkey c monkey do is
it
do you really think it's okay because i
still feel judged i feel like people are
giving you the side eye
it's not comfortable dr fauci we i know
yeah
we've got to make that transition if you
were vaccinated you don't
have to wear a mask outside it would be
a very unusual situation
if you were going into a completely
crowded situation
where people are essentially falling all
over each other then you wear a mask
but any other time if you're vaccinated
and you're outside
put aside your mask you don't have to
wear it
okay people are still judging and can i
just ask about you and rand paul does
your body tense up every time
in my body you know what i mean yeah
you know gail i i just don't want to get
into that tit
i just don't understand what the problem
is with him but
you know well i'm just going to do my
job and he could do what he wants to do
and we'll see what happens
yes well you are still dr anthony fauci
and we thank you for your time today
thanks we'll see you again thank you
very much yeah
good to be with you bye